over the weekend I was in Belfast
Ireland I had never been there before I
went to Belfast to work on a little
outside project
what's Kona gonna say when he finds out
that you went and did something else oh
wait you are Conan you're talking about
you're allowed to go do things no no I
just think it's funny outside project is
yes yeah I mean you know yeah I was
having plastic surgery okay that's what
I was getting I went to Belfast to do it
because I heard they do the best right
well they're the expert at Irish yeah
yeah so anyway I went to Belfast I had a
really nice time there I did some work
there while I was there this cool thing
it's kind of just funny thing happened a
carful of local Belfast kids drove by in
their car and they lowered the window
and I I could see they had like a iPhone
or something they filmed me drinking a
Guinness and they posted the footage
online and it got out there online and
then my own family was like sending me
the footage like my my brothers and
sisters in Massachusetts were saying hey
look at you anyway here's the footage
the kids in Belfast shot alright now I
was looking at that
look at that I was look at that and I
was thinking man I am a pro I mean check
that out I this all happened in a split
second I didn't know what's gonna happen
but I turned the label of the glass out
gave the big thumbs up like a pro like a
real spokesmodel well I should pay you
money if at some perfect ad for Guinness
yeah yeah and I agree with you I think
Guiness should pay me a little money
right that's out there I mean what
you've already done it I'm a huge
international star so I did this earlier
today don't gaffe at that that's a wheel
that wasn't there are points where I
listen for a laugh but when I say
international star I'm not waiting right
wow this guy is so famous that people
will actually slow their car down for
just a second that's how famous he is
that's pretty famous yeah sometimes they
used to accelerate anyway I had the same
thought as yes you I thought like hey
Guinness should make you know I should
get some money for that so I put a
little work into it today and I'm
putting this out there for the Guinness
people let's see if they come across
take a look ah Guinness the drink Cola
know Brian and Joyce when in Belfast to
reach Conan's representation for payment
contact Gavin Poland's
hot sand team's second for Westfield
Mall behind the Wienerschnitzel
Gavin oh don't be the money night Gavin
will get me the money
hey and guess what I'm no dummy I even
made one for Spanish markets take a look
ah
[Music]
eNOS la baby depravity today Conan
O'Brien development para conseguir
detalles sobre el borracho Napolitano
CEO of the single particle su
representante Gavin belongs dot Z Dean's
segunda Plata Westfield Paul the Gazelle
Wienerschnitzel
[Applause]
you